Londres dans les années 1960, tout le monde avait une histoire
sur le Crace, vous pouvez entrer dans n'importe quel
pub pour entendre un mensonge ou deux à leur sujet mais
j'étais là et je ne suis pas indifférent à
la vérité il y avait des frères mais liés
par plus que du sang il y avait des jumeaux  ainsi que les
princes gangsters homologues de
la ville qu'ils voulaient conquérir Ron Kray
était une foule londonienne assoiffée de sang
illogique et drôle aussi
mon Reggie était différent une fois dans sa
vie trouvez-vous un
homme de rue comme reg croyez-moi quand je le dis
Il m'a fallu beaucoup d'amour pour le
détester comme je le fais